Mike, give us the next story.
Okay.
So CNN reports, one homeowner in South Lake, Tahoe,
got a fun springtime surprise.
They'd been hearing a purring sound
under the floorboards for months.
Turns out there were bears under their house.
Whoa.
A full family of bears.
A mama bear and four baby cubs.
Oh, my gosh.
It's so adorable.
Experts say the homeowner was probably hearing
the bear's cozy hibernation sounds.
Snoring, breathing, nursing, maybe some rolling around.
The bears have safely returned to the forest.
Good ending.
My sister, Patty and I,
years ago, we went to Alaska.
We went to this place called Katmai National Park.
You go to bear orientation when you show up
and they teach you, if you ever see a bear
What to do?
You're supposed to clap, yeah.
Clap?
You go, (claps) "I'm right here, bear.
I'm right here. (claps)
I'm Mike. (claps)
You're a bear (claps)."
You know, just make noise, right?
Really?
So I was fly fishing
with this guide and my sister Patty,
and I hear my sister, Patty go, "Mike!"
and I look around, there's a bear,
about probably 25 feet from-
That's close.
Yeah, I know.
It was wild.
And I was so scared, I froze up.
And then the guide,
I'll step up for a second to explain this,
but it's like the guide snapped into action,
he sprinted at the bear and he goes,
"He-yah! (claps)
He-yah! (claps)
(Drew laughs)
And the bear just walked away,
like "I'm a bear", et cetera.
And I was so relieved
that my sister didn't get eaten by the bear.
But then I was a little mad 'cause I was like,
"You know, you didn't tell me about the He-yah! plan."
Yeah.
You told me to go (claps limply) "I'm right here, bear."
"I'm right here."
Okay, and finally.
(sighs) Oh my gosh.
We have a big wedding kerfuffle out of the UK.
Ooh, Mike, I think this one's gonna speak to you.
This comes from The Mirror.
The groomsman got into hot water with the bride
because he secretly ordered pizza to the parking lot.
(Mike laughs)
He says the veggies and salad at the reception
were not cutting it.
He needed a little more "fuel",
so he ordered pizza to his car, covertly.
But unfortunately, the other guests joins in.
And when the bride caught the groom, himself,
biting into a cheesy slice, she lost it.
(Drew mimics hysterical screaming)
This is, you know, bridal dresses flying.
Pizza's a solution for most things.
Totally.
(audience applauds)
Especially on Drew's News
A pizza pillow.
I know we do have plates out here, it's weird.
I don't know why.
Why do we have plates out here?
Oh my God, Kat!
Oh my God. (laughs)
(audience applauds)
Oh my gosh.
Are you kidding?
Thank you, Kat, so much. (screams excitedly)
Get in, get in.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Birbigs.
This is too much.
Get in.
I'm doing the right thing
by serving you guys first, that's love.
When I show up on a talk show and you serve me pizza,
I know I have a problem.
(Ross laughs)
(audience applauds)
Or-
No, you gotta figure it out.
We're just that awesome show
that wants to, like pizza, deliver.
Oh, Drew!
Rossy, are you proud?
I'm very proud of you.
Well, Mike Birbiglia, get more Mike on his podcast,
"Mike Birbiglia's Working It Out",
and I'm saying all of this with pizza in my mouth,
to honor your love of pizza.
And he has a solo show, "The Old Man and the Pool",
and it is coming to Chicago and LA,
so check the website for tickets.
I will be there.
(bright theme music)